joining us to discuss the ukrainian
refugee crisis are
china gadini williams head of global
communications at unhcr who's been on
the ground on the ukrainian border with
neighboring countries she joins us from
budapest and kate white emergency
program manager with doctors without
borders in geneva thank you both for
joining me on upfront china i'll start
with you unhcr is on the ground meeting
refugees from ukraine at the border of
neighboring countries can you talk to us
a little bit about the situation on the
ground uh what refugees have been facing
and how the organization has been
responding to it
yeah fortunately we've had a presence
both inside ukraine and in the
neighboring countries for about the last
30 years so we we had our teams ready um
when the first the war first broke out
and uh we've been at the borders in
romania and moldova and poland and also
here in hungary
the situation is right now it's very
well organized in terms of the reception
of refugees
but the
the clear um
the clear tragedy and the impacts on the
hundreds of thousands of refugees that
are arriving every day is is so visible
kate we're seeing an immense outpouring
of support for ukrainian refugees right
now doctors without borders
also has a presence in ukraine and your
teams are witnessing the impact of the
conflict on civilians
what are the biggest needs right now in
terms of support
i think in terms of support and what our
teams are seeing it it varies quite
dramatically depending upon where in the
country you are our teams in the east
around mario paul right now are
uh
basically just trying to survive given
their
completely cut off there's no water
there's no electricity they're running
out of food so really there it's about
safe passage for those who need to be
able to flee and ensuring that
humanitarian and medical supplies can
come into the city
further west in the country we're seeing
uh both indirect and direct consequences
of the war in terms of from a health
perspective
trauma patients that are
really creating a significant burden
on the
remaining functional health structures
and then beyond that
there are multiple needs in regard to
pre-existing conditions of people that
are being exasperated because they no
longer have access to health services
china
what kind of challenges do you
anticipate refugees will be facing in
the coming months we know that the
situation is developing very quickly on
the ground
i think one of the things that we're
most concerned about is that the people
that are arriving now are the ones who
have means they have resources they have
family they have connections either in
the neighboring countries or further
afield
what we're really worried about is that
the people who have not crossed yet are
the ones that will be more at risk
we're talking about
refugees who will be elderly or living
with disabilities we're also talking
about uh people who probably have less
in terms of resources and ability to
move out now
the other issue that we cannot avoid and
this will carry on for the next months
is that every single refugee family that
comes across are separated from loved
ones they've left
loved ones and family members behind and
this will weigh very heavily on the way
that we are able to respond to their
needs in the coming months uh kate
headlines are proclaiming that europe
has opened its doors to ukrainian
refugees and that quote eu nations
unanimously agreed to accept ukrainian
refugees for three years without going
through
asylum process now while we can agree
that these are positive moves to be sure
why have the doors been shut to african
asian and middle eastern asylum seekers
for so long
that's a very very good question that uh
i'm not sure i am able or qualified to
answer but indeed in terms of
of what we've seen as meta san francis
responding in various countries within
europe to to refugee crisis this is
dramatically different from how it has
worked in the past china there are some
pretty stark shifts for example just a
few years ago hungarian prime minister
viktor orban was building barbed wire
fences and barriers to keep refugees out
creating teams of border hunters border
hunters to stop asylum seekers and said
quote for us migration is a poison we
don't need it and won't swallow it now
he's welcoming ukrainian refugees in
with open arms uh similarly poland began
constructing a wall to prevent asylum
seekers from entering the country uh
through its border with belarus an area
where at least a dozen asylum seekers
froze to death this past winter now
they're building a rail link to ukraine
to help refugees enter
poland
i want to keep building on this
what do you think is behind this shift
not just in rhetoric but also in
practice
i think one thing that is um critical
here and
there's there's nothing positive that's
coming out of this war but i think one
thing that we are focusing on is that
this is an opportunity to shift this
narrative to say that
that
if shared
the responsibility of welcoming and
supporting refugees is manageable we are
able to do this
european countries and international
community overall is able to do this the
other thing that i've seen here and
i was at the railway station today here
in budapest and i saw
two trains arrive filled with refugees
from ukraine and many of them were
actually third country nationals so a
lot of students from africa i spoke to
several from tanzania from congo and
from ethiopia
they also were saying look right now
ukraine is our home we were you know one
of them was just about six months away
from graduating so they're they're
really unsure whether or not they want
to try to wait and see if they can go
back and finish their studies and i
think what we've seen in hungary is that
they're saying anyone coming from
ukraine right now we consider a refugee
and they're being treated exactly the
same which
as you say is is something that we
welcome china there are many uh africans
and south asians currently living in
ukraine who have faced significant
delays or even been completely blocked
from leaving the country for example a
nigerian national father of three said
he and his family were asked to give up
their seats on a cross-border bus out of
ukraine with ukrainian military officers
saying
no blacks allowed
can you speak about what black and brown
residents are facing when they try to
flee this war
i think in terms of um
unhcr's position we've made it very
clear there can be no discrimination
based on nationality ethnicity or race
people that are fleeing from ukraine
regardless of their nationality or
background
are fleeing the same conflict
and they deserve the same right to
access asylum and to
have have safety
that said
in terms of what's happening inside
ukraine it's very difficult for us to
assess
we have
like you heard these incidents seen
these reports and we followed up both
inside ukraine and in the neighboring
countries to um
to work with the governments to make
sure that these are not policies um and
that they are not going to be replicated
and and so far we do have assurances on
on both sides that that anyone who is
trying to escape the war in ukraine will
be allowed to do so and will have
safety and asylum on the other side kate
is doctors without borders doing
anything to help
these racialized refugees
so for us we treat people regardless of
their their race ethnicity or background
but what we're seeing
more broadly in ukraine itself
is a difficulty for population as a
whole
to flee
particularly from areas in the east
where cities are becoming besieged and
populations are struggling to move out
and for us in terms of the services that
are being provided in the country
surrounding ukraine
these
populations can be some of the most
vulnerable and we're trying as hard as
we can to follow and to look into this
because
it's
it's extremely difficult at the moment
though to track what happens to people
once they cross the border
they are spending
one two days in reception centers before
moving on so this is the early days when
kate is there any need for a more
targeted response it seems that the
unhcr and doctors without borders has
effectively taken a colorblind approach
saying
whoever you are if you're in need we're
going to help but if there is a
a a
disproportionate number of racialized
people being mistreated being pushed off
of buses being denied access to refuge
might there be a need for these
organizations to actually
over correct for that by targeting these
racialized groups
no indeed so when we we look at
populations in a context what we are
looking at is what services are being
provided and who are the most vulnerable
and
we are in a similar position to to china
and unhcr in a way that whilst we hear
many of these reports and we hear it in
the news in terms of what our teams are
able to see right now
we're not actually able to see a
systematic
case of discrimination however
um given that it is so widely reported
it is one of the things that we're
looking at doing in terms of supporting
because then that becomes an extremely
marginalized population without the same
access to the system that others have
china we've also seen the media
including an al jazeera presenter come
under fire for the way that they have
described ukrainian refugees compared to
other asylum seekers some of the worst
examples include reporters and
commentators saying things like ukraine
unlike iraq and afghanistan is civilized
in that ukrainians have blue eyes and
blonde hair
how do these dehumanizing descriptions
affect how people
not just view but ultimately treat
asylum seekers
absolutely i'm actually glad you brought
that up mark because i think the way
that we talk about
refugees in general
across media has
it's become such a negative thing
refugee has become such a negative word
and yet i think
maybe the one thing that we're learning
in this crisis is that absolutely
anybody can become a refugee and um
and
i have to say one of the the journalists
that i spoke to recently said a similar
thing and i
i did ask him so
are you saying that if a refugee who
looks like me or who looks um
like uh somebody from africa are you
saying that this is different and and i
did i think it's important that all of
us
actually face this we we talk about this
and we talk about this difference now
what i can say is that
um
if anything this is showing that
life is very fragile and it can change
in a matter of minutes i i've met so
many people in the last week along the
border
who literally had
15 minutes to decide what to take um
because the shelling started getting so
bad or so close that they decided
instantly like we have to go and we have
to go now and so
i think the one thing that we can try to
do is not so much talk about how
everybody is like us
but really talk about how
we all live in a world that is
very vulnerable and very fragile and
that can turn on its head and
and so hopefully that will allow us to
have a bit more compassion
and to to really be a bit more open
about how we think about displacement
overall
i want to thank you both china and kate
for joining me on upfront
you